hola a todos esto sería lo que yo
llamaría un vídeo opcional en los vídeos
anteriores he hablado de lo que es la
regla de la cadena multivariable dando
una justificación que a muchos quizás
les habrá parecido poco rigurosa por
ejemplo yo consideraba cosas como este
estilo donde teníamos la derivada de una
función vectorial verdad y multiplicamos
por un pequeño incremento en t verdad y
nosotros decíamos bueno esto lo
podríamos cancelar y tenemos un pequeño
incremento en la función b y algunas
personas dirán
esto no es exactamente una fracción así
que en realidad es una derivada y lo
estamos tratando de forma incorrecta y
aunque eso es cierto la intuición que
vimos coincide muy bien con el argumento
informal que hemos estado manejando así
que vamos a borrar por ahorita todo esto
muy bien vamos a borrarlo ahora veremos
ese argumento formal que les les he
estado platicando verdad y sólo para
recordar más o menos la intuición que
hemos desarrollado nosotros digamos
teníamos nuestro
espacio de digamos donde vive la
variable de verdad que en esencia es la
recta real muy bien y además tenemos una
función de verdad que tiene valores
vectoriales que nos manda digamos esta
recta numérica
esta función be nos la nos manda la
recta numérica a este espacio que puede
tener varias dimensiones verdad el caso
quizás más simple sería el plano con dos
dimensiones podríamos tener el espacio
con tres dimensiones verdad en realidad
no importa la dimensión y luego tenemos
una función digamos nuestra función
efe que a este espacio de varias
dimensiones lo manda exactamente a la
recta de la recta real verdad entonces
esto sería nuestro espacio de salidas y
entonces en esencia cuando vemos la
composición demandarte mediante la
función de a este espacio de varias
dimensiones y luego aplicar
efe que regresa a una dimensión tenemos
una función que en esencia tiene una
variable y una salida verdad
por eso es que nosotros podemos tomar
simplemente la derivada ordinaria de
esta composición de funciones es una es
una función digamos en tradicional
verdad de una variable y una salida
entonces siguiendo la idea de lo que es
la regla de la cadena tradicional la
derivada de una composición sería la
derivada de la digamos función que ésta
fuera evaluada en la que está dentro
multiplicando por la derivada de la que
está dentro verdad que es justamente lo
que tenemos aquí solo que la derivada de
la función f
es un gradiente y la derivada de la
función de adentro pues es un vector y
el producto que tenemos que hacer entre
ellas es el producto punto muy bien
entonces para poder hacer digamos para
poder deducir esta fórmula siempre es
bueno partir de la definición
tradicional de la derivada verdad y esta
definición tradicional en esencia es el
límite cuando h tiende a cero y cuando h
cuando escribimos h en realidad
podríamos estar pensando en un
pequeño incremento en la variable t
verdad y esto será el límite de una cosa
que tiene aquí como denominador h verdad
y tendremos que evaluar
efe en vez de temas h
- efe debe de verdad esta es la
definición clásica de la derivada muy
bien en realidad esta parte de arriba
corresponde al incremento verdad estamos
calculando el incremento que tenemos de
esta función completa muy bien entonces
ahora sólo para para tener un punto de
partida vamos a recordar un poco de la
la intuición de la regla de la cadena
verdad entonces nosotros digamos
partimos de algún punto cualquiera por
aquí verdad y pensamos en un pequeño
aumento en nuestra variable t que vamos
a denotar con de verdad este pequeño
aumento en la variable t nos produce
digamos un pequeño aumento
nuestra función vectorial ve verdad
entonces y aquí tenemos digamos a donde
cae este punto bajo la imagen digamos
bajo la acción de nuestra función de
verdad entonces esto produce algún
cambio que podemos denotar como de
verdad y este debe en realidad será
proporcional al aumento digamos en esta
variable de verdad y de hecho el factor
de digamos el factor de proporción entre
este aumento y el otro pues será
justamente la derivada por eso es que
podemos pensar que cancelamos verdad
pero finalmente este pequeño aumento en
digamos en la función vectorial b nos
produce un cambio en nuestra función f
verdad y ese cambio está dado por la
derivada direccional en la dirección de
este vector debe verdad de nuestra
función f entonces con esta intuición
aquí podemos ver en este paso intermedio
que necesitamos calcular la derivada de
la función vectorial
así que sería un buen punto para
continuar digamos calculando esa
derivada a partir de la definición
clásica verdad otra vez tendremos la
derivada de nuestra función vectorial de
verdad y vamos a calcular la derivada
con respecto a t y esto será el límite
cuando h tiende a cero de b de temas h -
b dt y todo esto irá dividido entre h y
no hay que perder de vista que como como
se interpreta esto en realidad esto es
una diferencia de vectores lo cual nos
dará nuevamente un vector y vamos a
reescalar lo con este digamos con esta h
verdad que es un número que está
dividiendo a este vector entonces aquí
hay una multiplicación de una escala por
un vector entonces el límite de todo
esto será justamente un vector es decir
la derivada de una función vectorial
vuelve a ser un vector y solo para
digamos poder escribirlo
mejor forma vamos a considerar
justamente esto de aquí vamos a copiarlo
tal cual
y vamos a copiarlo y vamos a pegarlo
nuevamente aquí abajo entonces vamos a
decir que la derivada será igual a ésta
a este vector pero necesitamos agregar
también un error verdad es decir es como
lo que le falta a este vector para hacer
justamente la derivada muy bien entonces
lo importante de este error es que
tiende a cero cuando nuestra variable h
tiende a cero pues cuando h tiende a
cero justamente esto de aquí es la
derivada entonces esto tendría que ser
cero verdad y esto que hemos hecho aquí
será muy útil para poder manipular todas
las cuentas que vamos a desarrollar en
realidad como a nosotros nos interesa
saber digamos alguna forma de expresar
de de temas h pues aquí podemos observar
que aquí se encuentra justamente desde
temas h entonces si multiplicamos ambos
lados de esta igualdad por h veamos qué
es lo que obtenemos obtendremos h veces
la derivada de
con respecto a ti pues era justamente ve
de temas h - vedette verdad es
justamente este numerador y que dicho
sea de paso pues esto es justamente lo
que estamos pensando como nuestro cambio
en la función de verdad podríamos
pensarse como ese pequeño empujoncito
que tenemos en la dirección de la
derivada verdad entonces por supuesto
éste es sólo el primer sumando y además
tenemos otros otros sumando verdad
a veces la función error verdad lo que
es el error lo que le faltaba a este
número para hacer a este vector perdón
para hacer la derivada y nuevamente voy
a introducir un poquito de notación esto
lo voy a denotar como o minúscula dh y
en realidad esta es una convención o
digamos algo muy muy común cuando uno
está trabajando en análisis matemático
verdad porque una función que es o
minúscula de h significa que al dividir
la norma de esa función entre la
variable h éste tiende a cero cuando h
tiende a cero entonces puedes observar
que h por vih es o minúscula de h ya que
al dividir esto entre h sé que suena un
poquito como a trabalenguas pero pero al
dividir esto entre h simplemente nos
queda el error y el error sabemos que
tiende a cero cuando h tiende a cero
verdad entonces pero bueno solo es un
poquito de convención verdad y ahora
podemos despejar quienes ve de temas h
que era lo que
necesitamos justamente aquí arriba
verdad entonces ve de temas h ve de
temas h
simplemente despejando será vedette
pasando digamos sumando lo del otro lado
será de t
a veces la derivada de b con respecto a
t y luego tenemos menos algo que es o de
h muy bien entonces en realidad este
menos puede ser más no importa en
realidad todo esto no es una función
simplemente es la notación verdad
estamos diciendo que es algo que sea
pachorra muy muy muy rápidamente a cero
cuando h tiende a cero muy bien entonces
ahora lo que podemos hacer es regresar a
nuestra definición digamos que queríamos
estudiar justamente esta de aquí vamos a
estudiar esta definición muy bien y
vamos a copiarla aquí abajo para poder
seguir trabajando con ella muy bien esto
era justamente lo que queríamos calcular
y ahora vamos a hacerlo solo que vamos a
sustituir esta vez de temas h por esta
expresión que tenemos aquí entonces esto
será el límite cuando h tiende a cero de
la función f evaluada en vez de t
+ h veces la derivada de b con respecto
a t por supuesto todo esto va evaluado
entre verdad todo esto va evaluado entre
menos o menos nuestra función o de h que
es esta cosa que sea pachorra muy rápido
verdad y luego simplemente tendremos
menos
efe de tdt verdad hasta este momento
todo esto que sustituimos era
simplemente verde temas h aquí copiamos
vedete de perdón
efe dt y todo esto lo dividimos entre h
muy bien y aquí viene digamos la parte
interesante este o de h como ya dijimos
es algo que sea para churra muy muy
rápido cuando h tiende a cero se hace
muy rápidamente 0 entonces podríamos por
un momento despreciar este término
verdad vamos a ignorar sin embargo ahora
lo que tenemos aquí verdad
justamente una pequeña desviación en la
dirección de la derivada de b
de nuestra función vectorial de verdad y
si omitimos esto y observamos qué es lo
que nos ha quedado justamente estamos
viendo que tenemos un aumento en la
dirección de la derivada y esta es la
definición de la derivada direccional en
la dirección de las derivadas de nuestra
función de verdad
otra vez suena a trabalenguas por lo que
acabo de decir es que esto es la
definición de la derivada direccional en
la dirección de la derivada de b
y esto de nuestra función efe evaluada
en btt muy bien esto es la derivada
direccional y justamente tú dirás bueno
falta más para llegar a la fórmula que
tenemos arriba como calculamos la
derivada direccional pues simplemente
será el gradiente de nuestra función
evaluada en el punto que se encuentra
aquí y hacemos el producto punto con la
derivada de btt
así que si subimos a ver todo esto
coincide con la intuición que habíamos
generado en vídeos anteriores verdad
digamos y hacemos pequeños empujoncitos
y en esencia toda la manipulación
algebraica que hemos hecho en este vídeo
fue para poder expresar este empujoncito
verdad del bdt + h y resultó ser el
vector original acá lo teníamos abajo
resultó ser el vector original más
un pequeño empujón en la dirección de la
derivada de be y bueno además tenemos un
término de h que se encoge muy muy
rápido verdad y en esencia al final
terminamos con una fórmula verdad
terminamos con la formulita de las
derivadas direccionales así que espero
que esto satisfaga a los que digamos les
gustan los argumentos más rigurosos y
quizás sea bueno ir mencionando que hay
una fórmula más general para la regla de
la cadena de funciones vectoriales
pero ya llegaremos a ello cuando veamos
la conexión entre el cálculo diferencial
y el álgebra lineal pero por ahora esto
es lo que necesita saber nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo